-Welcome back. We are
hanging out with my co-host
Jack Harlow right here,
ladies and gentlemen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah!
He's currently on tour
with his album
"Come Home the Kids Miss You,"
which is out right now.
Pick it up right now and
check it out on all the Spotify
and all the things
you listen to music on.
-Yes. Yes, please.
-Thank you --
Thank you for being here, buddy.
You know, I think you were
a musical guest in 2020.
-That's right.
-It was your
first TV appearance.
I think I heard "Whats Poppin"
and I Shazamed it,
and I was like, "This kid.
Who is this guy? Jack Harlow?
He's amazing."
And they called up.
And someone was like, "I don't
know if he's ready for TV."
I mean, the song just --
-Well, I hope
you take this the right way.
I feel like you were very early
for late-night television.
[ Laughter ]
And, I mean --
I feel like a lot of artists,
when their song finally is
in super rotation on the radio,
then it's like,
"Okay, let's get him up here."
You were, to me,
a tastemaker in that moment.
You were super early, so --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's what I'm talking -- See?
Thank you.
-For real.
You were -- You were really --
You were really early on that,
so thank you for having me.
-But I love that you came on
because I was like --
It really was your
first TV appearance,
and everyone on your team
was a little kind of nervous.
You weren't.
You were like, "Let's do this."
-Oh, I was. I was nervous.
-You were?
-Yeah.
-You didn't show it.
You killed it.
-Can't show it.
-Yeah, you can't show it.
And then it's so fun to watch
your career rise and rise.
And I recently got to
see you at the VMAs.
Congratulations on
winning all of those.
-Thank you.
-All of those Moon people.
-"First Class."
That was awesome.
That's got to feel good.
-It feels amazing.
Song of the summer.
-And then --
and then you asked me to...
to be in the opening with you.
-Yeah.
-To which I was like,
"Absolutely, buddy.
I'll do anything for you."
So, "First Class,"
you did in it, like, a --
Like, we were
in an airplane together.
And so -- Yeah, there's me.
-Wow.
-That's me right there.
-I forgot how cool you looked
in this moment.
You looked --
[ Laughter ]
-I looked pretty cool
right there.
Yeah, I was, like,
just chilling out, man.
Yeah, exactly.
It was me and Lil Nas X there.
I think Avril Lavigne
is on this plane somewhere.
-Yeah. All the legends.
-Yeah, we had -- we had --
-Nimo.
-Oh, yeah. Who --
-I think Saucy Santana's
back there. Chloe Bailey.
-Saucy Santana was there,
as well.
-That was a fun moment.
-But then you came out and
kind of co-hosted the VMAs.
But who is -- who is this guy
you came out with?
-I'm so glad you asked.
-Who --
-This -- His -- His appearance
was off script, you know,
because I was already co-hosting
with the legends Nicki Minaj
and LL Cool J.
-LL Cool J, yeah.
-So they were expecting me
to go out on my own, do my part.
And I was -- been sitting
with Druski throughout the show.
And I was like, "Yo, you want
to just come with me?"
So this is -- this is Druski.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So you just grabbed him
and go, "Hey."
Does he even have a microphone?
-It is -- This is one of my --
This is one
of my truest friends.
He didn't have a mic,
but he would just bend over
and talk into mine.
[ Laughter ]
But I was telling you
before the show,
you got to get him up here.
You got to get this --
This guy right here.
-Druski.
-He -- If you don't know --
[ Cheers and applause ]
If you don't know,
keep your eye on this guy.
This guy's a genius.
-Okay, good. Alright. Druski.
Yeah, we're coming for you, bud.
Alright. Alright, yeah.
I thought it was great.
You came out, you performed,
you were so good.
And I know you -- you sample
a little bit of Fergie
in the song "First Class."
-A lot of bit.
A little bit, a lot of bit.
Yeah.
And you brought out Fergie,
and the place went nuts.
-Crazy.
-And here she is.
You and Fergie.
Yeah, that's pretty good.
And I -- I heard a story
that you once tried
to perform Fergie at school?
Like, in a talent show
or something?
-There was, yeah, a talent
show when I was in fifth grade.
I tried to do "Fergalicious."
[ Laughter ]
It's a true story. True story.
And, you know, the lyrics
are suggestive, I guess.
To me --
To me, it wasn't anything.
-Yeah, you didn't get it
when you're in fifth grade.
-I didn't even
get to finish the audition.
I was halfway through,
and they cut me off.
They're like,
"You can't do that."
So, that's --
that's my rapper origin story.
-Yes. Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
And then, just recently,
by the way,
you're in the "Time" 100 Next.
You're on the list, buddy,
right here.
There's Keke on the cover.
[ Cheers and applause ]
There he is. Right there.
Jack Harlow right there
on the "Time" 100.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And they -- they asked me
to write your intro.
-Yeah. They know
the connection we have.
-Yeah, yeah. Did you know
I was going to write it?
-I had no idea. I woke up to it.
And --
-Yeah, we didn't tell you.
-Once again, thank you.
It's been cool to climb
the ladder with you.
You know, different steps away
from the VMA performance
to, like you said,
the first time I came on here.
-Now you're doing
Barclays Center tomorrow.
-Crazy.
-I mean, that's...
[ Cheers and applause ]
How is -- How's the tour going?
-It's phenomenal.
It's my first time
with a live band.
-Yeah.
Do -- Do you like touring?
-I actually like it a lot,
especially in the U.S.
I like the bus life.
I've gotten sick of the airport.
So, to me, being able to be in
a bus and wake up in a new city,
like, it's the dream.
-I was telling everyone today,
you pulled up in a tour bus
this morning.
-To 30 Rock.
-Yeah, right to the --
-We were --
We were coming from Toronto.
And we left, I think,
at around 5:00 a.m.
-Yeah.
-So, we pull off.
And we thought we were
going to get here at 1:00.
And then I wake up at 3:00,
and I open my shades,
and I look out and I'm just
seeing skyscrapers and taxis.
-Yeah.
-And I realize we're so late
that we're headed right here.
-You didn't get a chance
to go to the hotel.
-Yeah,. It's like,
"Let's -- Let's go. I'm ready."
-Yeah, exactly right.
You came and showed up.
Is your --
Is your mom, I know,
super proud of you, right?
Yeah. And, yeah, she loves
everything you do.
I heard the -- the story.
You guys would freestyle
in your car?
-Yeah. Yeah, when I was --
when I was super young,
I would plug up to the aux
and put on beats from YouTube.
-But your mom would freestyle,
as well?
-She would --
And she would freestyle with me.
And we would go back and forth.
-That's a mom.
That is a supportive mom
for you right there.
-Trust -- Trust me, trust me.
-You know what I'm saying, bud?
What would your mom
freestyle rap about?
-Oh, she was dark, man.
[ Laughter ]
-What? That's so funny.
-No, she would say things
I can't even say on live TV.
-Yeah, of course.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then you actually used to
record music videos.
And this is something
you brought us.
I appreciate this. This is
one of your earliest raps.
Take a look at young
Jack Harlow.
♪ Oh, I've been getting busy
-working on my next track ♪
♪ So don't get mad
if you try to text Jack ♪
♪ And he doesn't text back,
I mean, I'm sorry ♪
♪ I wish I could make it
to your birthday party ♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's a -- That's a good rap.
Don't be mad
if I don't text back.
-Listen, man.
I'm from the trenches, man.
You know?
-I'm happy that you're here.
We're going to interview
Dwyane Wade together.
But I just want to say congrats
on everything, bud.
It's always a pleasure
to watch you.
Keep going up higher
and higher and higher, buddy.
-GOAT.
-Come on. Jack Harlow.
-The GOAT.
-Jack Harlow, everybody.
For more information on the
"Come Home the Kids Miss You"
tour,
go to jackharlow.us.
Jack and I will be right back
with Dwyane Wade.
Stick around, everybody.